is it fair to say that actually to be on
target you need to be net winning over a
thousand seats well we need to take
every seat we possibly okay I know but
I'm asking you the number I want to put
this in the context because you know
there's lots of comparisons to you know
elections in the past and I get that but
the election we're fighting is coming
off the back of the 2019 general
election which was the worst result for
35 years and many people said to me when
I became leader of labor party which was
just under three years ago good luck
here but you'll never do it in five
years and here we are yeah before
election and you're challenging me as to
whether on course for a labor Victory
quite right too yeah um I'm not going to
go into the numbers of seats we want to
take every seat that we can you seem to
be doing everything out of a Blair
Playbook talking tough on crime Purge in
the left but your party is lacking
something that Tony Blair had a sense of
excitement do you understand that people
don't feel that enthusiasm stick about
you at the moment and that could be a
problem well let's deal with a Playbook
issue because tough on crime isn't new
to me I've been dealing with crime for
many many years I've spent five years as
the chief prosecutor in England and
Wales Prosecuting criminals every day of
my life so this is not new and and the
reason I did that then and the reason
we're being so strong in this now is I
know what effect it has on lives and
wherever you go whether it's Swindon or
anywhere where else and ask people how
do you feel at the moment most people
say the last 13 years I haven't seen my
wages go up living standards haven't
gone up our schools and our hospitals
haven't improved and I want change but
what I most want to know is how I can
pay my bills what are you going to do
about the longer term issues the NHS is
on its knees so you know I think we're
in one of those moments in history where
people want reassurance that you get it
you understand what they're going
through and you've actually got the
concrete answers to the challenges of
the future I mean I did a focus group in
High Wycombe a couple of weeks ago and I
went up to Pendle uh this week actually
to talk to voters they do talk about
change but I have to say they also say
they're not sure about you so they want
change but they're not sure that they
like the cut of your jib that is why the
local elections are so fantastic because
we can be out across the country uh here
in Swindon today across the whole of the
country for the next few weeks talking
to people having those conversations and
as soon as we get the chance to do that
and as soon as people hear what we're
offering the positive case we're making
like today for example saying we're
going to freeze council tax next year
using the windfall tax that hasn't been
collected by the government people say
that would really help me I like that so
I think there is a sense that we need
changes we desperately need a change in
this country and second on council tax
you say you'd freeze council tax this
year if you were in power will you make
the same commitment that you would
freeze it if you were in government in
2025. well you know 2025 is two years
away and if you think back two years we
wouldn't have known precisely the
position we'll be in but it's not
hypothetical because the money that
we're suggesting could be used for it
the windfall that's 10 billion pounds
it's on the table the government could
do this tomorrow we would vote for it we
could do this I do need to ask you
before I let you go about another labor
leader because last week Labor's
governing body approved your motion to
block Jeremy corbyn from Stan as a labor
candidate he described it as a shameful
attack on Democracy I don't ask you did
you feel bad about it because back in
April 2020 you described Jeremy corbyn
as your friend and now you've kicked him
out there's only real bad there's one
person who is responsible for the fact
that Jeremy corbyn will not be a labor
candidate of the next election and
that's Jeremy corbyn and the first words
I said as labor leader was that I would
root out anti-Semitism in my party and
I've been absolutely ruthless in that
there's always more work to do but I set
out to change the labor party and to
change it in relation to anticipation
and I said I'd root it out and I am
delivering on that pledge what one final
thing people will remember though you
standing shoulder to shoulder with
Jeremy corbyn saying he should be prime
minister and now you they see you
stabbing him in the front some people
will think that do you worry that voters
might think that either you're not to be
trusted or they might conclude that with
friends like Kia who needs enemies well
we went into that 2019 election and the
electorate gave their verdict on the
labor party as it then was I took the
view that you don't look at the
electorate and say what on Earth were
you doing you look at your own party and
say we need to change and that's why
I've been so clear about changing the
labor party whether it's rooting out
anti-Semitism being absolutely clear
we're pro-business pronato and facing
the voters and being fit to serve the
country no apologies for that because
what I want uh is a labor government and
only with the labor party that's facing
the voters that is answering the
difficult challenges of the future do we
get the right to be heard and to earn
those votes that we need to get a labor
government you're prepared to be
ruthless to win I'm prepared to be
ruthless to ensure that we have a labor
government I have been ruthless in the
change in the labor party I do not
apologize for that because what matters
most to me is that the change that
millions of people desperately need
across our country comes about that will
only come about if I ensure that we've
got a labor party that is fit to face
the future fit to face the voters and
has the answers to the difficult
challenges that face the whole country